this new piece of information right it
changes a question ever so slightly we
can use so much of what we've already
worked out I think actually all the hard
parts right and use that to work out
well how far do I need to go before I
can now say all right now I could put in
my news piece of information and I can
go on from there okay I think the
critical line I wonder if you compare
where did you pick up where you left off
I think the critical line is this one if
you've gone further than that
like if you climbed further back up the
question in like maybe you can't hear
you like I don't need to regenerate this
series all over again and then I have
two kids all this stuff out hopefully
you recognize as you cancel this line
with a very very minor adjustment should
reappear right which tells you oh okay
this is read support me here's what I've
got
let me rub off this stuff so I can pick
up from here
Oh remind me remind me what is that
thing on the left-hand side like it's
algebra but what does that algebra
signify it's a it's a ratio right what's
it a ratio between yeah good it's the
ratio between two subsequent terms right
now tell me when you divide so I'll come
back over here when you divide the next
term by the previous one the next time
by the previous one right number one
you've got these coefficients right but
then you also have if I don't think
about just the coefficients but I think
if I think about the term right the
whole time including the X's if I divide
the whole term it will be this car fish
it but they'll result the extra hanging
on what's the extra bit it'll be the X
term right in fact it's not just the X
term it'll be exactly one X you see why
there will be one X right because
there'll be there's one X and then
there's two and there's three so if I
divide say this one by this one right
you'll have one X leftover or if I
divided this one by the previous one
I'll have one X left over right and X
okay
except you know what X is it's 3/4
so therefore he's what she wants
you want this that's what you want that
to be only difference okay there's the
extra X that we have when we take into
account not just the coefficients but
the whole term including that one X it's
gonna be hanging around so now I just
proceed the way I did before I just I
can do a bit of simplifying right kids
let's zoom out there this will become 7
minus K on the top okay
and then you solve just the way you did
before and I think what you get is this
is what I in know it okay is less than 3
and 4 bits
okay I think that's my good so therefore
for K equals 0 & 1 & 2 & 3 that's when
the coefficients keep climbing okay they
keep close
so therefore which is the important one
it'll be coefficient number 4 right
that'll be the one where they stop
increasing after that this will be the
peak okay now what actually what is well
what is the greatest coefficient so you
chop it in here's the here's the general
term so to be c4 I should say t4 which
would be 7 choose 4 for lots of that and
3/4 to the power of 4 right because
there's all my there's my X to the 4
then you can work that out what do you
get 100 in something bigger okay now are
you convinced
I hope the algebra balls together right
but just so you can see it do you mind
sibling community we can do the same
thing as before right so here you can
see what I have already built beforehand
what does this represent in case you
didn't see before
you've got your I'm just gonna
you've got which term you looking at
this is the resulting binomial
coefficient this is how much the answer
2 to the K will be where'd that come
from
that came from here that to right now
this is what happened when we put
together all of these guys and these are
the coefficients but now I want that
specific value of x 3/4 right so here we
go point seven five that's three
quarters I'm gonna raise it to the power
of whatever term on one IMU right so
that'll be this guy so in the first
place
well three coins the powers your own q1
right so power of numbers turn out
bigger now you don't need to work that
out what am I gonna get there if I were
the actual turn it'll be the
coefficients you worked out before and
now these specific values events so it's
gonna look like this that coefficient
times that's particular value of x okay
so you get something pretty boring talk
but now do you recognize it I can't hold
on for the sake of it since since we can
let's let's do some different ones shall
we let's go not too much it too much my
eyes
so again you can see there he is there's
the most green one okay oh maybe that's
maybe that's confusing you too much too
much too much rain guard for me add this
let's do that again
so you can see there's the deepest one
there's the peak that's the greatest
coefficient that you already worked out
177 and then 3/16 okay